need to change your mind because some of  you are thinking about giving up because  you're in a season of failure but just  because you failed doesn't mean that God  doesn't have a bright future in store  for you it is always too soon to quit  but I want to remind you that failure is  not final it's formative it is part of  the process it's part of the journey  your failure matters as much as your  success  how do you think you're gonna grow if  you don't ever fail  that some of you have failed and you  have decided well guess what I'm a  failure no failure is an event it is  never a person just because you failed  doesn't mean that you're a failure in  fact failure is actually fuel for your  future the way that you grow the way  that you advance you have to fail in  order to succeed like every one of my  successes is stacked on top of failures  you need to get a revelation day that  the joy is not in the success the joy is  in trying the joy is in the process